tonight we wrap up our three-part series
on the future of American farming last
night we told you how difficult it may
be to continue the generations long
tradition of the family farm because of
factors including difficult trade
policies with nations such as China and
the possibilities of more tariffs
tonight a bit of optimism correspondent
Doug mackelway tells us there's a new
generation of farmers in America coming
from a most unlikely place big cities
that's what show you how full they are
some might think CJ is Bella's risking
too much considering the declining
fortune of the American family farm but
here he is selling the very beef poultry
and eggs he raised as a new farmer on
the land whose ancestors tilled trying
to seize on that market opportunity by
that void is why we got into producing
it and we were fortunate in that aspect
to be so successful with the timing CJ
is at the forefront of a renaissance in
small farming he's hedging against
farming's inherent risk by holding on to
a second job as a DC firefighter with a
specialty in rescues I love being a big
City fireman and then coming home to the
country thousands of others like CJ are
returning to the land combining
old-school farming with 21st century
marketing many beginning farmers are now
starting in a directory so tell sort of
a business like selling direct at a
farmers market or through a Community
Supported Agriculture subscription sort
of a marketplace lobbyist Gary Madison
should know in two weeks he's leaving
the Washington rat race returning to his
family farm in New Hampshire to raise
beef hoping to capitalize on a new
retail trend to grow and eat locally we
all used to eat local food right I mean
food was grown near us and our diets
were regularly changed by what was in
season near us and you know we had
regional foods Congress's intent on
expanding opportunities one bill
sponsored by Senator George Leader Mitch
McConnell would remove hemp from the
Controlled Substances Act with its soil
replenishing qualities and uses and
fabric food lotions and anti-seizure
oils many farmers are convinced it's a
potential replacement for a bygone cash
tobacco time and again they shared with
me their enthusiasm for him potential to
re-energize agricultural communities and
advocacy group the new Young Farmers
coalition believes Congress isn't doing
enough noting the farm bill now under
consideration needs more incentives to
attract young farmers to this
risk-filled occupation 97% of farms are
still run by families it requires
long-term patience a trait not often
appreciated by the young or by any of us
whose sustenance literally depends on
farmers right Doug thank you